hey guys my name is Jess it is the third
of August and you're watching games
footage does it have explained after a
little bit of outrage why the overwatch
some against items are restricted to
loot boxes the Olympics seemed cosmetic
items are only available in special Luke
boxes that will disappear in three weeks
and unlike existing items you can't
purchase them with credits that said
every time you open one of the special
loot boxes you are guaranteed at least
one of the new items game director Jeff
Kaplan explained that this is because we
want the items to feel extra special and
very rare so we don't want everyone
running around all the time in every
single summer games item and we actually
don't expect that all players will get
all summer games items we want this to
be a thing where six months from now
when the summer games are long past you
look back on somebody using that cool
Sun the game Daria skin and go oh man I
can't wait until next year when Summer
Games happens maybe I'll be lucky enough
to get that skin of course with standard
loop box items you can't work your way
towards collecting every standard item
next up Pokemon go deaf niantic are
revoking legendary Pokemon in order to
make things fair earlier this week a
player got their hands on the legendary
Pokemon Articuno to the dismay of many
other players at the legendary Pokemon
have since been removed niantic told
GameSpot we recently noticed that a few
legendary Pokemon got into a few
accounts when they shouldn't have to
preserve the game's integrity and as a
measure of fairness we have rectified
the situation and revoked the legendary
Pokemon from the trainer's accounts
additionally a number of players haven't
been too happy about the most recent
update which removed the broken Pokemon
tracking feature instead of fixing it my
antics say the feature was removed in
order to encourage the underlying design
finally a have discussed their sales
expectations for battlefield one and
titanfall 2 and since there's nothing
sexier than sales expectations let's
talk about that EA say they are
optimistic battlefield one can exceed
its conservative projection of slightly
under 15 million units which is what
about a field game typically sells as
for response titanfall to CFO Blake
Jorgensen said the first titanfall did a
little more than 7 million units last
time it was early in cycle one of the
few titles out there we think titanfall
2 will do more than that but it's
probably closer to 10 millionth and it
is 215 as a comparison although we don't
know exactly how many units call of duty
black ops 3 sold we know it was a single
best selling game of 2015 and the series
sales total over 250 million units
worldwide ala field one will be out on
October 21 while titanfall 2 is jus just
a week later on October 58 EA say they
aren't worried that the games will
cannibalize each other's sales insisting
that shooters are a massive genre with a
diverse set of players looking to
fulfill different gameplay motivations
be sure to check back to GameSpot's two
stories on inside and no man's sky and
I'll have a bunch more news for you
tomorrow